اذا ما هو هرمون الحب
الاوكسيتوسين هو ناقل عصبي للدماغ له دور
مهم في العديد من السلوكيات في البشريه
والتفاعلات الاجتماعيه بما في ذلك الثقه
والاثاره الجنسيه والارتباط العاطفي وايضا
الترابط بين الوالدين والرضيع افرازه هذا
الهرمون يرتبط على الاغلب بوجود شخص اخر
اي شكل من اشكال الترابط الاجتماعي او
الاتصال الجسدي الايجابي يمكن ان يحفزه
هرمون الحب حتى خلال مشاركه الوجبات مع
اشخاص نحبهم بطبيعه الحال تمتلكه النساء
اعلى من الاكسيتوسين مقارنه بالرجال حيث
يساعد الهرمون على تحفيز الرحم اثناء
المخاض والولاده وتحفيز انسجه الثدي
للمساعده على الرضاعه بعد الولاده رغم ذلك
الاوكسيتوسين لا علاقه له مباشره بمشاعر
او الاستقرار النفسي بل يمكن ان يكون
مسؤلا ايضا عن مشاعر سلبيه مثل الغيره
والحسد والشماته